look around you
almost everything you see is the product
of intelligence of human intelligence
the Magnificent theater where in the
cloth we're wearing the ideas we're
sharing intelligence is the creative
principle behind things like the theory
of relativity the Mona Lisa the idea of
democracy so now imagine the
possibilities if we could create true
artificial intelligence if we could make
intelligence abundant through computers
I'm here to tell you that there is
nothing more human than the pursuit of
artificial intelligence I'm a research
scientist a deep mind an artificial
intelligence research lab our goal is to
create through artificial intelligence
through AI why we believe that
artificial intelligence is a tool that
can help us solve some of the world's
most complex problems problems like
climate change clean energy access to
water and fighting disease artificial
intelligence offices a chance to
accelerate progress on questions like
these by acting as a multiplier for
human ingenuity but in order to create
artificial intelligence we first need to
understand exactly what intelligence is
the hallmark of human intelligence is
its generality nobody has expressed this
idea more vividly than science fiction
author Robert a Heinlein
a human being should be able to change a
diaper plan an invasion butcher a hog
Connor ship design a building write a
sonnet balance accounts build a wall set
a bone comfort the dying take orders
give orders cooperate act alone solve
equations analyze a new problem pitch
manure program a computer cook a tasty
meal fight efficiently die gallantly
specialization is for insects after
sifting through over 70 definitions of
intelligence my colleague Shane leg
arrived arrived at a very similar
conclusion intelligence measures an
agent's ability to achieve goals in a
wide range of environments or in his
favorite language so let's unpack this
definition who or what can be
intelligent the answer is what we call
an agent someone or something that can
take action this could be a human being
it could be a machine it could be a
piece of software in order to be
intelligent an agent needs to be able to
achieve goals but not just a few or very
specific ones goals in a wide range of
environments clearly the definition
calls for a generalist specialists need
not apply so how would you go about
building an intelligent machine here's
an idea for every task or problem
think about how a human would solve it
then take the human solution and encode
it as a set of rules for the computer we
sometimes call this approach go fie
good old-fashioned AI this plausible
approach has been tried but
unfortunately it has mostly failed the
reason people are incredibly good at
solving problems but incredibly bad at
explaining exactly how they do it so
what else can we do
let's turn to the one living proof that
human level intelligence is actually
possible our own human minds I don't
know what your experience is
but in my experience when we learn we
learn from experience when we apply that
very idea to computer software we call
it machine learning you can think of
machine learning as a new way of
programming a computer we don't feed it
rules or instructions instead we let it
learn from examples and experience hence
for the remainder of the talk the
protagonist will be an artificial
learning agent that interacts with the
world in three different ways
it observes the state of the world it
takes action in the world and it
receives rewards for achieving goals the
learning agents brain is an artificial
neural network that's a computer
architecture that's inspired by the
human brain during training it learns by
adapting the connections between its
artificial brain cells the goal to take
actions that lead to the greatest reward
in the future so as an example for
training let's take our best friend and
learning agent the dog and cat lovers
will understand why we're not using a
cat here
what would you do if you wanted to train
your dog to sit on command first you
lure it into a sitting position then you
utter the command sit and then you
reward it with a treat as you do this
again and again the dog's brain learns
by adapting the connections between its
neurons to get the treat so artificial
learning agents are trained in much the
same way as this and that's what we call
machine learning science-fiction you
might be saying not at all
the mobile phone responding to your
voice commands your photos automatically
tagged by content your messages
translated into a different language
online all of these systems have been
trained by machine learning by feeding
them examples not rules but for true
artificial intelligence where will all
the experience and the rich interactions
to learn come from surprisingly we can
find inspiration in Stefan Zweig famous
book the Royal game the book tells the
story of dr. B an innocent man who has
been arrested and is being held in
solitary confinement
not unlike our learning agent dr. B is
alone in a small world and starved for
stimulation they did nothing to us other
than subjecting us to complete
nothingness for as is well known nothing
on earth puts more pressure on the human
mind than nothing one day while waiting
for an interrogation dr. B manages to
steal a book from one of his captors a
book about the game of chess
eager to engage his mind dr. B devours
the book and learns to play chess he
replaced the master games in the book
again and again but after a while those
games have lost their novelty desperate
for further diversion dr. B attempts to
play chess against himself but he soon
realizes that in order to play chess
against himself he needs to split his
mind into two halves and I black and an
eye white now only now with two agents
in play can there be true interaction
and learning years later on a cruise
ship dr. B meets the world chess
champion of the time one Mirko sent
ovitch an expert at chess and only at
chess in a stunning demonstration of his
skills dr. B manages to do the
impossible he wins at chess against the
world chess champion
fast forward 80 years and Stefan Zweig
story becomes reality in a way that not
even the author could have imagined the
modern sent ovitch stockfish computer
Chess Champion 2016 a good old-fashioned
artificial intelligence for playing
chess and only chess the modern dr. B
alpha zero an artificial learning agent
that learns to play chess solely by
playing against itself and not just
chess also the difficult games of shogi
and go in a match of 1000 games alpha
zero wins 25 times as many games as
stockfish and according to former world
chess champion Garry Kasparov
it did so in great style indeed so how
does alpha zero work as a zero is a
learning agent that much like dr. B
begins with zero knowledge about the
game of chess except for the rules when
it starts playing against itself it
plays more or less randomly but at some
point it stumbles upon a victory and
that's when the magic starts happening I
for zero begins to learn it learns by
adapting the connections between its
artificial neurons to make more
successful moves more likely to be
played as it becomes a better player it
produces even better games from which to
learn in only eight hours alpha zero
learns more about the game of chess than
had been learned in the past fifteen
hundred years but can our learning
agents go beyond pure competition and
become team players after all we humans
thrive on cooperation in order to find
out we trained our learning agents on
another game capture the flag in capture
the flag players team up to capture the
opponent teams flag while protecting
their own in the video game players
control the movements of their avatar
and they can tag opponents here's a
video showing how to capture a flag on
the left you'll see the agent
perspective and on the right you see a
top-down view so run to the opponent
base and pick up the flag then bring it
back to your own base but in order to
score you need to make sure that your
own flag is at your own base at the time
similar to alpha zero we train the
learning agents by letting them play
against themselves for me
millions of games but the environment
here is much richer than chess it's a 3d
environment and the agents need to learn
to cooperate as well as to compete and
because our goal is generality we train
them on a diverse set of maps with
different teammates and against
different opponents we were excited to
discover that the learning agents
learned some rather advanced behaviors
for example they learn to defend their
home base they learn to set up camp in
the opponent base to wait to the flag
there reappears so they can capture it
and they learn to follow their teammates
because then they can work together
eventually the learning agents became
stronger at the game than strong human
players against the fixed pool of
opponents the learning agents won 74% of
their games as compared to strong human
players who only one 52% of the games
but what surprises the most was that the
human players preferred to play with the
artificial learning agents on their team
they said they were simply more skilled
and reliable but enough about artificial
learning agents what have we as human
learn learning agents learned so far may
be that the pursuit of artificial
intelligence is a more human endeavor
than we thought after all we take
inspiration from human intelligence when
we say that the hallmark of intelligence
is its generality we take inspiration
from human learning when we say that
intelligent agents need experience and
not instructions and we take inspiration
from human interaction when we emphasize
that we need to train our learning
agents together
to overcome the nothingness that haunted
dr. B in the story so to conclude using
our own human intelligence maybe one day
we can create true artificial
intelligence a tool that not only plays
games but that can help us tackle some
of the great problems of our times with
greater intelligence
[Applause]